be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on comic nation this is Rob
and as we move ever closer to Secret
Wars 2015 we pick up now with the
character of Captain universe now
Captain universe is a really cool
concept in Marvel Comics but prior to
Jonathan Hickman's run of New Avengers
and Avengers Captain universe really
wasn't that prominent and the reason why
I say that is there's a lot of backstory
or I guess there's some backstory but
it's really kind of scattered is
confusing and it's really nonsensical
but to really sort of make sense of this
the Captain universe is basically an
entity it's a cosmic entity not in the
sense of eternity or infinity or you
know any of those cosmic entities but in
the sense that it is a concept I guess
is the best way to describe it
Captain universe or the unit power
basically is this enigmatic energy
source basically meaning that models
never really explained it Marvel's never
really given us an in-depth discussion
or I guess an end up explanation in
terms of how the unit power has come
into existence in terms of where it was
that it came from it was basically just
there one day now captain universe or I
guess the unifor Spacek aliy bonds
itself to people in a time of dire need
for the universe as a whole and so the
result is that over the course of
Marvel's continuity the unit power has
taken over various people we saw that it
basically bonded with spider-man at one
point in time there were a series of
short limited I guess one-shot
publications whereby the you know Power
had bonded with a Silver Surfer bottom
with the Incredible Hulk so on and so
forth and again these are just sort of
small things now the current captain
universe in Marvel Comics is a woman
named Tamara DeVoe now we don't really
know a whole lot about Tamara Tabo and
in fact we don't really need to because
for the most part whenever Captain
universe bonds to a being again it's
usually for a temporary amount of time
in order for the universal threat to go
away and when it does then the unit
power dissipates and the person goes
back to who they were before but with
tamara DeVoe she appears in Jonathon
Hickman's run of Avengers or Avengers
vol 5 with issue number 1 or 3 I think
it's issue number 3 and basically she's
just there we don't really know where
she came from we don't know how she got
there she's simply just there one day
and so this really ties into the
infinity event which we're not going to
go into because at this point is really
not necessary but if you guys are
interested of course Benny has a video
that you're welcome to check out on his
channel I don't have a link down in the
description but suffice it to say what
basically takes place here is that the
origin story with a story of how it was
Samara DeVoe had become Captain universe
is given to us in Avengers issue number
6 and what we learn here is that Tamara
DeVoe was basically your average woman
she was a normal person and what had
happened was that somewhere along the
line she had gotten into a car wreck and
when she did she has fallen into a coma
now the coma that she was in lasted for
10 years but while she was in this coma
the incursian started happening the
death of the universe began to take
place I'm so sensing that something
needed to happen to restore balance to
the universe the UNEP a manifest itself
and when it did it chose to merge with
tamara DeVoe now the reason why the unit
power chose to merge with tamara DeVoe
is because as far as it explains the
universe itself was broken and tamara
DeVoe herself was broken and so it was
just a matter of compatibility for the
two of them to sync up now when a person
develops or I guess when they're bonded
with the you know power when they become
Captain universe it's actually not an
absolute thing there's to say it's not
as though they're given a fixed power
set instead it's actually subjective
based on the person if a street-level
person like the Punisher for example
were to be given the we're to be given
the unit power you would be able to
utilize its power far differently than
if someone like the Silver Surfer did
and the reason why is because the unit
power enhances the abilities of a
person's powers already but it also
takes their life experiences and it also
gives them all the experiences in the
memories of the previous captain captain
universes meaning that a person could
basically use their imagination to use
the power to its full potential but a
person with limited imagination would
not be able to do so and so again this
is really just a cure to this creative
for the purpose of having a new
superhero in the realm of any given
conflict but to also keep the powers of
that superhero confined to the abilities
of the person it possesses that way they
we really don't have a situation where a
person pops up and fans say well why
don't why does it catch the universe
just fix everything
why does the captain universe just snap
their fingers and the threat goes away
and that's that it's basically an answer
to that question and so again we don't
really know what we're going to see with
captain universe going into the future
of Marvel Comics especially into secret
Wars but because captain universe is
effectively the universe incarnate
because it exists to protect the
universe that would go as far as to say
we'll probably see more involvement with
copy universes time progresses and we'll
probably see some derivative of captain
universe going into Secret Wars 2015
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
ah